devastating questions and that have been
suggested to me and others I thought up
and I want to go with almost with the
theme that Marla ended up with but also
that Steve had throughout its
presentation is this list this construct
observation of variability heterogeneity
diversity in the patient population in
at time do you think that's going to end
up being chaos and yet at the same time
I wonder and and I got some suggestion
from Steve's presentation as well as for
Marla's is there in the heterogeneity in
that diversity in the variability in the
presentation is there a diamond is there
something there that's important Steve
and I'm going to turn to you on that
yeah yes but not always that's what we
do as scientists we look for outliers to
kind of guide the way forward and
develop hypotheses so I can think of a
few examples which I did not show I
actually took one the slides out just
before my presentation I mentioned the
one region that's a copy number variants
that's been defined for many years it's
a region on human chromosome 7 I studied
this in my PhD thesis and if you're
missing one copy of this 1.6 million
chemical base region on chromosome 7 it
encompasses 16 jeans you have a disorder
called Williams syndrome Williams buren
syndrome and it's very very predictable
of what the outcome is including the
behavioral outcome and then more
recently it's been found that if you
have three copies of that gene it's you
seem to have a neurodevelopmental
condition that is very reminiscent of
autism and that what some people are now
actually calling autism so too much lead
you in one trajectory and too little
leads you in a different trajectory
these are pretty predictable so in a way
i do think i agree with what Marla said
but I also I think we have to remember
that we are our DNA is a blueprint but
we're very hard wired that's why you
look like your father
you look like your mother that's
controlled by the genes so but but it's
true we in the pursuit of scientific
investigation we follow these types of
leads and I gave you one example there's
lots of others we have some unpublished
data now where we're getting a little
bit more specificity I was talking about
it today in my presentation the meeting
we're getting more specificity as we
increase the resolution and we have
these new technologies that get us down
to the specific genetic alteration not
just kind of an assumption where it
might be and if we have good clinical
details we can make much more positive
correlations so I think there are
examples more examples coming but it's
not a perfect science I mean we're
studying behavior here or follow its
complexities our load this in it did you
want to add anything to that for me
based on your comments or you're okay
with that and i will go to another
question I would say that for behavior I
wouldn't say want to say that we're
hardwired as much as maybe some physical
characteristics sorry I would say that
the term of hardwired in a DNA blueprint
one has to think about which particular
traits are talking about and so for
something like a physical characteristic
having a Hitchhiker's thumb or not I
don't it's a single gene trait or some
traits that are single gene that we know
about like Huntington's disease cystic
fibrosis then we can talk about a
genetic blueprint but when we're talking
about traits like normal variation and
behavior and maybe some of the
behavioral traits for some of these
disorders it isn't a one-to-one mapping
necessarily of gene and behavior we have
mutations in an A in one an autism gene
and yet it's not completely penetrant
right that that child doesn't ended up
with it so the genetic gives us a
predisposition but I think we don't want
to give up on understanding things above
the environment that could be
interacting somehow with that
predisposition that's true that would be
my just leaning
I mean we know through behavioral
studies and animals and in humans that
we are hard-wired maybe maybe a better
term is were soft wired but but in fact
a lot of a lot of things and each of us
can tell stories about our spouses but
you know my suppose would say you're
stubborn you got it from your dad and I
have many attributes that are probably
hardwired based on my genetics so you
couldn't change your stubbornness you
know I can and this is how science
advances this is really bad two days of
this a little more sophisticated than no
you're not no that was that argument as
as well it does come out every now and
then it's science so I want to I want to
go to have the Kia have to kill your
clinician yet you're you're leading this
this the pawn network and how is basic
science going to assist you or sis
clinical work in general what why why
basic science well I'm a neurologist and
when I was training my supervising
urologist every time I saw a child he
would say where is the lesion so we cut
trained to identify the lesion
unification a stroke you look for the
signs of the stroke and then you figured
out where in the brain that stroke
localized when I so child with autism
spectrum disorder my supervisor asked me
where is the lesion and I had no idea
where the lesion was and very quickly
realized that without understanding
where the religion is there is very
little opportunity for innovative
therapeutic development for for making
big improvements in the way we treat
kids because we don't understand the
biology we don't understand the lesion
so what basic science does for me is it
gives me illusion once we have the
elision once we know what their
molecular target is the biological
target is then we have tools and there
is huge technology development happening
at the same time that allows us to get
much better developing new tools to
actually develop treatments at target
seclusion but we need the lesion right
so lesion has a metal
or the metaphor for understanding the
mechanism actually what's underneath
which is the issue and I think if you
think a bit about the debate that that
Stephen Marlowe has happened was exactly
that I think back and forth
understanding the mechanism the hardwire
with what's happening on how you
interface with how this is expressed and
I think that may be another way of
phrasing that marla i wanna i would i
want you to think big where the
breakthrough is going to come through
where where how do we get the word of
where we're going to go so i think one
of the things that has to be done and i
know it's it's being started already as
to bring people from wide wildly
different fields and areas together who
wouldn't normally find themselves in the
same room at any meeting to work at the
edges of their discipline it sounds like
a sea farm model but to really push them
to address the questions and that way
and it's the same in my lab you you get
out of your rut of thinking in a certain
way and you hope to make big innovative
discoveries so i would say that's how to
do it and there are many groups starting
to do that including it's here in
Toronto at SickKids right in other words
thinking differently about approaches
and sometimes we need to have the
conflict to be able to say which is one
or the other my why essentially why our
workshop for two days was to bring in
people of diverse backgrounds Steve I'm
going to go back to you and I am going
to end up in of the key with a
devastating question for us to Kia that
we're all dying to ask but I'm letting
her prepare herself there but Steve I
want to go back to the thing that you
said because I'm a neuropsychologist you
describe the whole issue of behavior and
you talked about the diversity from the
social cognition versus the quote
executive and in my domain that would be
both of those are related to frontal
lobe functioning this is the area of
research i do yet we've also taken a
look at and referred over the two days
this whole issue of networks and systems
so to talk to me and even though it's
not your field so how do you see that
area pursue
we nor do you feel that I'm that's not a
fair question to ask you that's
definitely not a fair question asked I
told you I JoJo's gonna ask why don't
you time this is your area of expertise
maybe what I will say is you know I I
presented a presentation of the things
that really excite me and and I think
we've seen more progress in the last few
years that are really revolutionized the
way we think about autism okay I think
the concept of molecules meeting at the
synapse and the develop of animal models
based on human mutations that now seem
to be reversed by in phenotype using
specific drugs or training behaviors and
things I think this is really exciting
it's what we've been looking for but
saying all of that we've been looking
under the lamppost we have these massive
data sets that we could generate by
genomics proteomics imaging and we tend
to look for things that we find simple
or can explain so maybe I'll be no
politician here I'm changing your
question to come back to the question
honest Marla really and this is what I I
think the reason for the meeting was is
to bring mathematicians and
statisticians and modeling people to to
the four so that we can actually really
start to understand the depths of the
data and what it should be telling us as
opposed to looking for what we think it
should be telling us so that's where we
need that was my last slide and that's
where the breakthroughs are going to
come at the interface of these
disciplines and thinking about new ideas
so for example in autism you know why
are we studying males so much i'm at
four to one male we do a collection we
should really be studying females
because perhaps the clue at shank one
family i talked about is trying to find
a genes that are protective all right
that will give us the clue of actually
developing treatments may be easier to
protect and actually replace or correct
so those types of bright ideas coming
from bright people but i think using
different approaches and put in
exploiting the massive
that we can develop technically but
actually bringing them to completion
actually is a kind of an answer that I
wanted and I just as an aside it wasn't
unfair question I was asking see but one
of the constructs is is about thinking
broadly is that some of the work that
I've done I've actually board from the
autism research to do in adults with
stroke so this idea of pushing the
boundaries across and you can borrow
from every anywhere to come across with
ideas that help you to understand the
question that that that you're pursuing
in the patient population that you're
pursuing so I think you're you're
spot-on with with your with your
response now i'm going to ask of the key
the question that everybody wants me to
ask everybody's dying is that as will
there will ever be a cure so i mean it
is it's a theoretical possibility but i
don't think that should be the focus for
a couple of reasons one is our brains
the plains of kids who have autism
spectrum disorders get wired differently
from the beginning so by the time I
babies born their bait their brain is
wired differently so it's extremely
unlikely but we're going to have
manipulations that we do afterwards that
would reverse the original wiring that's
one way to look at it the second way to
look at it is you may not want to change
it so we're all wired a little bit
different name produces variability it
keep produces innovation but it's some
conflict then when it gets generated
good things happen and so we don't
really want to be all the same we don't
wanna get rid of all the differences
what we want to do is we want to
decrease the stress we're going to
decrease this function we want to
improve quality of life so the purpose
of of our treatment strategies should be
to allow the difference but take away
the distress so it is not like a person
who is not particularly socially
motivated will become a social butterfly
after the treatment it says that we want
the person who is not socially motivated
and is feeling and it is really becoming
a little bit of an outcast to
the ability to interact to have the
ability to have an interview to have the
ability to get the job that actually
matches their skills to have the ability
to get satisfaction out of their life so
I think that goal should be focusing on
quality of life and and removal of
distress and less on whether in one day
we'd be theoretically possible to cure
the disease thank you did you what well
you know I don't disagree with anything
that she said but there are parents who
want their child treated towards a cure
certainly severely autistic conditions
that are medical genetic disorders that
can lead to a very debilitating
lifestyle so I don't think we should
forget that also in fact that really
drives our research forward we want to
understand all the things I talk about
but ultimately we want to provide better
treatment options for these people who
really need to have medical health help
on the entire spectrum from what you've
said to what this is the absolute
challenge in the field I mean we're
dealing with as I show to my slide a
disorder that ranges from a glenn gould
to a severe medical genetic disorder